STEPHEN CARPENTER: We think
about conventional activities
to expand thematic and
conceptual exploration.
So the traditional ways or
maybe more conventional ways you
might think about art education
or learning studio practices--
sculpture, working with
clay, working with wood,
working with paint,
or drawing practices--
those are fine if we want
to develop a set of skills.
But what about thinking about
concepts and themes and issues?
Well, we might as well get
started and do some of that
now.
So we're going to make
a little transition.
I'm going to set up a
still life over here.
And we're going to
do some drawing.
The range of ways
in which people draw
is perfectly acceptable,
perfectly acceptable.
So if you're concerned
that it's tough for you
to draw a conclusion or
draw a straight line,
don't be concerned by that.
It's the process that
we're interested in,
not the visual representation.
We have the three
chairs in the center.
With your marker, I would
like you to draw what you see.
And you can draw it
on this paper the way
that it makes sense to you.
If you want to draw it as
large as you can, that's great.
If you want to draw it
smaller, that's fine.
But here's our still life,
these three chairs kind
of sitting in relationship
to each other.
We'll take about 8 to
10 minutes to draw this.
Oh, but there's one thing.
This is my-- there's
one more thing.
You'll draw for 30
seconds at a time.
And then after your
30 seconds is over,
I have another task for you.
So you're going to draw
the chairs for 30 seconds.
And then I'll give you another
step to continue your drawing.
Got it?
All right, so when
you're ready, set, go.
It's not a race.
Just go, time starts now.
Try to put in as much
information as you can.
All right, stop, stop.
Now, what you're
going to have to do
is slide back in your chair,
slide back a little bit.
And then stand up.
And then move one
drawing to the left.
So now you're standing in front
of somebody else's drawing,
to the left.
OK, stand in front of the next
person-- the next drawing.
All right, now keep drawing.
Continue the drawing that
this other person has started.
Go.
All right, stop, move.
Did you learn
something about drawing
from other people's drawings?
Like as you went through
and you sat down and said,
oh, there were some things
happening at this new drawing
that you're sitting at
that you hadn't thought
about that maybe you
tried to replicate
or you tried to avoid.
LARRY SUSSKIND: My
attitude toward what
I was doing changed rather
markedly in different parts
of the circle.
I started out with trying to
take the assignment literally.
And I assumed that
somebody else, that's
their representation of that.
It's my job to add--
to complete their
representation.
But about over
there, by that time,
since I couldn't figure
their representation
relative to what I was looking
at, that I finally decided,
well, I could contribute
something to this,
but it isn't their
representation
that I'm helping to finish.
I'll just focus on adding
solid surfaces to ones
that don't have solid surfaces.
Because clearly, there
are some solid surfaces.
So as I moved along, I was
making sure I added something.
But I wasn't any longer
trying to complete
what the message was
that the previous person,
that the original
person had left.
By the time I got
over there, I realized
people were adding things
that were extraneous
to the literal assignment.
And I said, oh, I see.
This is just a picture now.
This is no longer a still life
that has to be represented.
Now there's people just
making it into a picture.
They're putting things that
are not there in the picture.
Oh, OK, that's fun.
And so now I realized that
the assignment had changed
or my conception of it
had radically altered.
And then by the time
I get back to my own,
I recognized nothing.
And I said, OK,
well I can barely
find what I started with.
There's layers of what
other people produced.
But my sense of what
I was doing changed
as there were changes
imposed by many people
before me getting
to the picture.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Man,
that's such a wonderful--
I want to transition to
the next drawing task.
But inherent in what
everyone was saying
could be applied to other
tasks, other subjects.
Imagine if we didn't have
a set of chairs there.
Imagine if there
was a person there.
Instead of drawing
with lines, we
were drawing with the questions
we were asking this person who
we had never met before.
Or maybe we had passed
this person numerous times
like we pass these
chairs all the time.
These chairs are
just in the room.
But now we put them
in a space of inquiry.
Oh, now I have to look.
I've learned some things about
these chairs in this circle
that I didn't realize
about the chairs
before, just by the
act of mark-making.
So what if we put
a person there,
someone we may pass on
the street everyday.
And we just, we stopped--
instead of drawing them--
we could draw them-- what if
we asked questions of them?
What if each mark
that we're making
is some form of a question
that we're asking?
How much more would we
learn about that person
just by talking to them?
The idea here will be that
we'll still use the chairs.
And we're still building
on this premise of learning
from each other's drawings.
But now instead of us
all drawing and moving
to each other's
drawings, one person
will take the drawing
implement and you
will be connected, fixed
to that drawing implement.
In other words,
you're an extension
of that drawing implement.
And your partner
has to find a way
to use you, the drawing
implement, to draw the chairs.
All you're doing,
drawing implement,
is holding the marker.
The person who is your
partner is using--
they might have to hold
your hand or your elbow
or your shoulder or
shoulder and wrist.
That's why I'm saying need
to have the permission
of the other person.
And then they're going
to draw what they see,
they're going to draw
the chairs using you
and the marker as the implement.
And you're the implement.
You're kind of in it to see
how this drawing turns out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
So some of the words
I'm hearing that, to me, work
in tandem with this notion
of themes or concepts--
responsibility, influence,
some notion of liberation
in what you said over
there, right, cooperation.
So these are themes
or concepts that
might be important to many
disciplines or many discourses.
But one way we might get to
it could be doing an activity
like this, even though
this activity could also
be taken very literally in
terms of formal approaches
to revise and enhance
the way people render,
through drawings, who
render realistically
the objects that they're seeing.
But there's also
a conceptual piece
here that we don't want to miss.